hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to other
edition of ask Evan today I mentioned a
question from one of our YouTube viewers
Mohammed love the YouTube viewers thank
you who wrote in with a question my
question is what is the ideal place to
put a boutique or a shop and be
successful so thanks to the question
Mohammed really you want to be where
your customers are and so you had to
figure out I don't know what kind of
boutique you're trying to set up for
what you're trying to sell but you want
to think about where are your customers
and helping to be around them now
setting up a retail shop is expensive
right you have to have a location you
have to have inventory and I'm generally
at the view of trying to boost up a
business as much as possible not
spending the money till I make you money
so how can you apply that to your
business and make sure you get in the
right location a lot of entrepreneurs
who are starting these businesses out
and who are creating their own retail
locations a lot of them fail and a lot
of it has to do with having a bad
location or having the wrong products or
services for that that specific location
so you don't want to mess up you want to
get it right I don't want to see you
spend a lot of your time money on
something that's not going to work out
my advice for you is to scout a few
areas and see where your ideal clients
you think are hanging out so if you're
targeting young men or older women or
whoever it is see where they're hanging
out right now Scout a few locations and
I try to make a partnership with
somebody who's already selling in that
area and I would look for somebody who's
not your direct competitor somebody who
has complimentary products or services
to what you're selling and try to find a
way to either have a one-day sale where
you can go in and market your products
or services or you have a little booth
as a part of their store or little table
as a part of their store a lot of these
entrepreneurs who have these locations
are always looking for new ways to bring
people into the store and also to drive
new revenue for them if it's a big
franchise location the polygon the same
no but if it's an entrepreneur that you
can go in and connect with one on one
and say you know I want to create a
little booth here within your store and
I want to drive traffic to it I want to
help from
then that's a really low cost way to
test out that market right so if all you
have is one little table within a store
that's already in a potentially ideal
target area then you can test it you can
see you test it for a couple months are
your ideal clients coming in is that a
good fit for you are you able to make
sales from it are you selling the right
products or services and you're doing it
with relatively low inventory and either
relatively low rent or no rent at all
depending on the arrangement you make
with your partner there and then you can
see if you're making a lot of money if
it's going very well that's the best
case scenario then you can look at
getting your own store really close by
and your customers will come with you if
it doesn't work out and you know you're
not getting the business that you
thought you were you're not getting
traction you're not making sales then
you're not out a lot of money and you've
been you've been able to test that
market or a really small scale so that
would be my advice to kind of try things
out before you invest huge amount of
money into any new location and a good
way to test out potentially multiple
locations you could try you know two
months in one place if it doesn't work
out go somewhere else was somewhere else
but try to have a hit list of your kind
of one to three top places that you'd
like to open up and use that as a
strategy to get started and hopefully
increase the chances of you being
successful so thanks for the question
mohammed i love the questions from
youtube for those of you watching if you
liked the video please give it a thumbs
up below always makes you want to do
more for you and if you have a question
about your own business or comment about
this video for Mohamed please leave it
in the section below in the comments I
always read those and i always reply so
thank you and i'll see you on the next
episode
you